you're an interesting man  Scotland  [Applause]  you're an Avenger  [Music]  you have a daughter  but you've lost a lot of time  like me  we could help each other with that  who are you  I'm the man who can give you the one  thing you want  what's that  time  [Music]  I can rewrite existence  and shatter timelines  you cannot trust him I don't care who  this guy is I just lost so much  he can give us a second chance  [Music]  let me make this easy for you  he will bring me what I need  or everything you call a life will end  up  you may not want her to watch this we  had a deal  you thought you could win  I don't have to win  we both just have to lose  I'm sorry Cassie  [Music]